Eran Sandhaus, thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me, Michael.
I am so excited. So excited
because I'm gonna get
so much inspiration now
about mobility,
about your experience as an entrepreneur,
as a board member and advisor,
but most importantly
about where we're headed
as a community of innovators
past covid-19.
Eran, let's just start.
Who are you?
Besides the fact that I know you
from J-Ventures
and all the fun that we have there,
who are you?
Wow.
What a big question, Michael.
Well, let me try to summarize it
maybe in a few words.
So, what I'm really passionate about,
I would say, is the human spirit.
Okay.
Who I am is, I like to,
first of all I really love technology.
I believe in technology,
and I'm someone that
likes to make things happen
in ways that are highly accelerated,
which is why technology
is important for me.
And the other thing
that I really care about is people.
Okay and social change and social impact.
So if you kind of look at who I am
I would say that I'm the combination of two of those things.
Okay. That's at a very high level.
Let me share with you
the rest of my journey.
Okay. So you started out in semiconductors
and in Texas Instruments and Qualcomm,
you find your way more
to an entrepreneurial position
and very excited about mobility.
What is it about
the entrepreneurial mindset and mobility
that really got you excited?
Yeah. So, as you said,
I started my career in semiconductors
and I ended up almost by mistake
getting into mobility.
So, the common denominator in my career
in the semiconductor space is that
the early years were engineering,
but the last decade
I've managed all the businesses.
And all of them were about
creating a startup inside
the large multinational.
I was the crazy Israeli guy that said,
"Okay. Bring this guy,
so he can make this vision.
So, how can we grow the company?
How can we create this new business?"
So I would come in and kind of I parachute in.
Get the lay of the land,
recruit the team, start to grow.
And I've done this for a very long time
because I really enjoyed the scale
and the breadth of what you can do
at the global scale
with a large multinational.
And that gave me a great career
for quite some time, about 18 years.
But two and a half years ago, I actually,
So, this was about 15 years of my career.
And right after that,
what happened is
I got recruited to move into mobility.
So Delphi Automotive were looking
for someone to lead their autonomous
vehicle business.
I met with the CEO
and we really hit it off
with a great chemistry.
And I asked him one question,
"Why are you interested to hire someone like me"
'cause I'm not from your business.
I came from semi."
And he said, "It's very simple.
I look for someone who's,
in the automotive world
we're very conservative.
We think about safety.
I want someone with a mindset
of making things happen
and has no fear."
Okay -
Now, when is this?
Around when are we?
This was the end of 2016.
2016. Okay.
So, right at the end of 2016.
And I came out of the room.
I got a call from the recruiter
an hour later that said they want me.
And because fundamentally,
they figured out that
if you would have me on board,
I can help create a business,
which again, most people
totally think would be crazy to create.
And I took the job
and I fell in love with that mission.
You know, when you think about
self-driving cars,
the promise behind it,
as I said, I really care about
the social impact as well.
You know, it started
with reducing the casualties.
There's over one million people
dying every single day,
40,000 in the US
Sorry every single year.
Yeah.
And 40,000 people in the US alone,
normally not with Corona -
Every single year.
40,000 people -
Every single year 40,000 people
in the US die from accidents.
It's literally like a 747
going down every day.
Okay. So, this is a major, major thing.
And by the way,
most of the one million people
are coming from Asia.
Of course, there's more people living there,
but there's a lot to be done.
So, you know what?
It was very compelling for me
and for the team that they built was
how can we go and literally save lives?
And the second piece that is really
appealing about mobility
it's about reducing the cost of travel.
Okay the cost of movement.
And if you think about
what it is movement,
it's enabling people
that are outside of the cities,
that are living far away,
that don't have access.
All of a sudden,
it becomes affordable for them
to connect to the city to get employment.
Okay. So, this is something
that could literally reshape
what it is to have like a city,
what it is to live in a suburb,
what it is to be outside.
All of a sudden you get connected.
Right.
It also ... the time to be productive
the time that you travel.
So, I'd love to get your insight into
because you're an expert in the industry,
and you're an advisor and board member
of a bunch of these companies
that are making groundbreaking work
in mobility and autonomous vehicles.
Yet here we are in 2020.
We've been hearing about this
notion of autonomous vehicles,
autonomous mobility for quite some time.
I've talked to quite a few people
in a variety of these
edge technology companies,
and it seems like we're
at the 95% stage.
And that extra five percent
is very, very difficult
and we're not gonna get it on the road
until we get that five percent.
Is that the case?
What's happening today?
Sure. So, I don't think we're at the 95%.
We're at the 80% stage.
So, there's a lot more to be done.
I'm really bummed out right now.
I was very optimistic coming in here.
But let me tell you,
when I was recruited
into Delphi,
we believe that by 2020 or 2022,
there'll be self-driving cars everywhere,
ubiquitous.
Not only you.
A lot of people thought that.
Right. And a short while after I came in,
I realized that that's not gonna happen.
There was a lot of stuff
that has to be resolved.
However, when you think about it,
it's probably it's not gonna happen
the way that people wanted,
but it is gonna happen
a different way.
And it is gonna go sooner
than people think now.
And what I mean by that is
originally people thought that
their using Uber and Lyft,
it's gonna go self-driving car.
That's it. Okay, 2022, a very high percentage.
That's not the case.
However, you can now take the same set
of capabilities that have been developed
for that market
and apply them in other places
that are very profitable,
lucrative and very relevant.
So, for example, one of them is trucking.
Okay.
When you start to think about it,
there are already businesses
with built business models
that you can start to automate
and make money today.
They're very relevant.
So trucking is an industry
that there's a shortage of drivers.
There's a lot of things that you can do
once you start to move to
self-driving trucks. You can do deliveries at night.
Also some things that would really
alleviate a lot of network.
And the other thing, by the way that sprung,
a lot of people started to pivot away
from doing the self-driving taxis
to delivery robots.
In the last two to three years
and now you can start to see
pilots already going on
with Postmates, for example,
both in LA and San Francisco,
they moved to deliveries
with driverless robots.
And you can see also in downtown
Mountain View ... doing that.
Wow.
So that trend is gonna start
to look different than what we thought,
but it is coming sooner.
Personally,
I'm also working with the world's
largest public transportation company.
And they're also working publicly
on the project now for 50 pilots,
five zero pilots globally
for self-driving shuttles
in different location.
Amazing.
The point of what I'm trying to say
is if you start to narrow down
what it is that you do,
this problem starts to be manageable.
And that's what people are doing now.
So was the problem that
five, 10 years ago,
people were making these
huge remarks
and huge aspirations of
every car in the world
is gonna be autonomous.
And now we're just narrowing it down
into manageable pieces?
Is this the transition that we're seeing?
Yeah. What happened is
a natural process in the market
of like a shakeout
for product market fit.
So by and large the product,
the companies went to
minimum viable products.
Most companies
pivoted to where the money is at.
And therefore we started to see things
going into agriculture.
Mining is also going up.
Construction.
... operations
that they're going
to inside of warehouses
for e-commerce is booming.
All of that started
to really grow rapidly.
And you still have companies
that are doing robotaxis.
So, Mobilize working on it.
You've got Zoot that's
been required by Amazon. And Aurora
So there are a bunch of companies,
but they're gonna take longer.
So, it's just been separated from this
huge monolithic thing that we're gonna
see 100% to this spectrum
of things that are out there.
I love it.
Eran, what's happening now?
You know, we're in the midst of covid-19,
we all hope that it would end
just as fast as it came.
It's not gonna end anytime soon.
We're experiencing all these new realities.
I'm fascinated every day thinking about
how our world is changing
and the workforce is changing.
And I know that I'm going
to build my own venture
sooner rather than later.
And I'm constantly thinking about
what is my role coming out of
or being a part of covid-19.
You wrote a fascinating piece on Medium
about our role as innovators
through covid-19.
What's your mindset about this?
What is our collective responsibility
as entrepreneurs and innovators?
Right. So, thank you for mentioning that.
The main point that I made in that article
When I look back at the crisis
that I experienced in 2000 and 2008,
those years were extremely difficult
and challenging in many ways.
But on the other end,
it really forced me to reckon with,
Okay what can I do to stay on top
and to innovate?
And to really have a profitable business.
So, talk to me
What happened in 2008?
Because that's also a really cool story.
Sure. So, in 2008,
I was working for Texas Instruments
for TI and we're selling chips
to cellphone companies.
And we had a really good business.
With a very good and diverse business,
but as you can imagine
when there's a crisis,
everything goes down.
So, in a short period of time,
our revenue went down
to pretty much to zero.
And we had hundreds of employees
on our payroll globally.
So, it was a very scary time
I would say as a person
that is managing this group,
we had to go through layoffs.
It was very difficult as well.
But we knew that it was not
gonna be the end.
And since I also had a strategy team
under my command, I said,
"Okay, let's go figure out.
Let's get in the room, okay.
And while we go through all this
very difficult period,
let's think about what we can create.
What we can envision"
And we decided to go outside of our
four corners and we invited speakers.
We brought speakers who are
like forward thinkers
and everything, researchers.
And we sat together and we came upon,
one of them started to mention
this whole notion on
machine to machine.
Okay. That one day machines
will start to be connected
and communicate with each other.
And you know,
it really sprung our imagination
because if we created these
wireless chips that you put in a phone,
what if you could actually take
the same devices
and that $100 million investment
that we do every year
to generate these devices
and now start to put it in everything.
So think about thermostats,
doorbells, security cameras.
You know, these are just -
I mean, today it sounds like a default.
Of course everything is connected.
But back then, in 2008,
in the middle of
a great economic recession.
Not as default. Right.
So, it did not exist.
What it causes, it kind of
reckon us to think about okay
what if we could do something different?
And we literally inside of this
entire huge issue,
we recruited a team,
a business team, first to go after
chasing all these people out there
to find out what's out there.
Kind of like sending the dove
in the middle of the flood.
And they went out and they
came back with an analysis.
Okay here's a market that we can do.
There's another one.
We should go after automotive
and everyone all of a sudden, first of all,
there was a whole burst of energy.
So, in the midst of that crisis,
we all started to get really
excited by that vision.
And 12 months later,
we had a business unit in place.
We started to allocate
engineering resources.
That was 2008 marked the beginning
of how we brought Internet of things
into Texas Instruments.
We ended up engaging with
with some of the top guys
between Google and Apple
and all these guys,
because no one would start
to brainstorm with them about the stakes.
So, it was actually one of the most
productive eras that we had that.
A decade later that business
became a booming business
and so did the company.
It started at that point.
So, my takeaway as an entrepreneur here is
you have a huge crisis on your hand.
Your current business is shut down
and you're almost forced
to make a decision.
You either sit down and wait
and moan in dismay,
or you can say,
"Okay well let's take this time
to understand the world better.
Pivot if necessary and discover things that
we might not have been able to see otherwise
because we never allocated the energy
and the mindfulness to be exposed to them"
Right. That's exactly the point.
You never wanna lose the opportunity
to address a good crisis.
That was something that was said by
one of the Obama advisors.
Right awhile back.
Never waste a good crisis.
So when you think about it,
that was the point of the article I made,
which is, When I look back in 2030,
okay, that's the challenge
I gave to everyone
at the end of the article.
Yes.
When I look back at 2030,
what is it that we'll be doing
now in 2020 that I'll be proud of?
And what is it that you'll be doing now
that you can look back and say,
"Oh, my God. That was something
that I created in this period of time"
100%. 100%.
So Eran, one of the things that
I've got to know you over these past few months
through J-Ventures is your kindness
and your motivation
to have social impact and social good.
What does that mean
to have social impact,
especially you know in our world
when it's very capitalistic
and we're constantly chasing our next goals
and our next titles and positions?
What is our responsibility also
for social impact?
Well, I don't know
what's our responsibility,
but I'll share with you
where I'm at in this journey, okay?
You know, a few weeks ago, actually,
I was very fortunate to attend a session
that Oded organized with Sir Ronald Cohen.
I think it was about four or five weeks ago.
And he spoke about social impact.
And it really struck a chord with me.
So I'm in this journey right now
to really figure out
what could be done with this.
And what was interesting
about this combination is
for the first time in my life,
I figured out that the two worlds
of social impact and entrepreneurship
and financial impact can actually be
joined together into something.
What made it truly interesting
in the talk with Ronald Cohen
was that he was talking about
what's really missing
in the world of capitalism today
and the way that corporations are acting
is that they're not measured in any way
shape or form, really,
on the social impact.
Some of them they issue reports and stuff,
but in reality they really measure
their financial impact.
And in the process,
they can cause a lot of harm
No one looks.
Now, what if that was not the case.
What if there was a scale literally
that you could measure
and quantify dollar wise
the social impact of a company?
That's a fascinating concept.
If you do that, you eventually start
to transform the playing field.
So, that's it.
That's in the realm of large companies
and the same thing
applies for investment.
Like what if we could literally
deploy capital
not only to invest in companies
that would be
extremely financially successful,
but in the process,
with great, amazing social returns.
And I think that that world
is really fascinating.
What I was not aware is that there's
multiple trillions of dollars that are
already operating in the space,
Like BlackRock and
... already put money
and there are already some VC firms.
So, for me, when I'm thinking about 2030,
I wanna be able to look back and say,
"Okay, I've created a dent
inside of that trend"
because there's something
that's for me personally,
I think it's very directionally correct.
Of course. So, as I'm starting my journey
as a young entrepreneur
and a lot of my friends from Stanford
and 8200 who are joining me
on this journey now,
what are some things with your experience
that we can take with us
as we're both looking to make a dent
financially and make innovation
and make a dent physically in the world,
but also with social impact in mind.
Because it still seems like there's a pretty
big dissonance between the effort
that we put into social impact
and the effort that we put
in to make a successful business.
They seem very separated.
And I'd love to learn for myself
how I can start combining them?
Yeah, I think the key element
is really to create a business
that the core business is the one
that creates the social wealth.
So, it's not like something
that is on the side.
It's not something that
comes in contradiction.
And there are businesses
that are 100% social.
Those are basically in the philanthropy realm.
There are businesses that are 100% business
and there's no social aspects.
The interesting part is,
can you create a business
that is 100% aligned
so whenever you grow
and you sell another unit,
you literally start to expand more.
Definitely.
And that's the way to think about it.
And the other aspect which is
critical for social impact.
It's not enough to have a declaration
to have social good,
but it's literally taking on and measuring it
and setting goals.
Which is very counter intuitive.
This idea of measuring your social impact,
not just saying
we are a socially conscious company,
but actually quantifying
how much social impact are we doing.
I mean, it sounds like
a whole different thing that
I don't think it's being taught today
in business schools around the world.
It sounds like what you're saying is that
this is something that should be taught
and that should be addressed.
Yeah, I personally think that's the case.
In general, I believe that,
whatever you cannot measure
you cannot manage.
Okay first of all.
And if you don't set a goal in the future,
it doesn't shape your
actions in the present.
Okay. So, think about it.
Any company that you talk to
comes with a declaration of
what their financial future will look like
in the form of their forecast.
If you start to literally think that way
that you're gonna measure
and put the social impact out there
and measure it backwards,
that's gonna shape your action.
And that's the biggest thing
that I will tell you.
Don't just settle and work for a company
that says we're gonna do good.
Because every startup that I see
says we're gonna do good.
No startup says
we're gonna destroy the planet
or abuse our employees.
Everyone says they do good.
But it's a completely different,
... to say not only are
we gonna do good,
but we're gonna measure it.
Okay and we're gonna publish it.
And we're gonna seek out investors
that want that.
By the way, if you do that
it will create the right culture
in the company
It will attract the right set of people.
You get the right set of board members
and advisors.
People that really wanna be there
because they really want the mission
to succeed in
a completely different level.
I love it.
Eran, we started with mobility
I'd love to end with mobility
from an aspect of
You've had the privilege of sitting
on a number of advisory seats
and board seats of a variety of companies
who are dealing with mobility.
And I'd love to get your take quickly
on this idea of not just mobility,
but working in an industry that is
constantly developing, that is really
moving the needle in the world.
What are some of your earned secrets
spending these past few years
really understanding this industry
and seeing all the different players
play a part in it?
Yeah, I think the biggest one is really
spending the time
to understand the pain points.
Okay, so there's a reason why I work
within companies
because I like to understand
where are the intersection points
between them and where are the seams?
Where things are actually not working.
So, that's a whole different animal
to have a conversation
But what I can tell you is that
the main value is not just understanding
what works well,
but mainly understanding what are
the challenges and what doesn't.
That's what's gonna set
the different blocks of the ecosystem,
how people collaborate,
the business models,
the value chain. All of that
I love it. Eran, right before we finish,
I have to ask the most important question.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or that Oded would use to describe you
or anybody that worked with you
would use to describe you.
Yeah. I would say passionate.
Socially aware or social impact
would be a good one.
And the other one I would say innovator.
I love it.
It's so not surprising that almost
every person I have this show with
says passionate.
It makes me passionate definitely.
Eran, toda raba.
Thank you very much.
And best of luck with everything.
I can't wait to see these things on the street
and seeing the world actually change.
And I promise here and I'm gonna look back
at this conversation in 2030
to think about social impact
in a more quantitative way.
And I agree that that's the way to look.
I think it's beautiful that every person
would love to say,
"Yeah, I'm doing good for the world
and my company is doing good for the world."
I'm taking from this conversation
I wanna find a way to quantify this.
When soon I'm gonna start my own venture.
So, thank you for that inspiration.
Thank you, Michael.
Let's create the future.
Okay, thanks.
Take care.